[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Öncelikle hepiniz hoş geldiniz bugün bu
sahnede olma amacım Türkiye'nin ilk
kadın milli motosiklet yarışçısı olman
bugün bu sahnede daha çok benim
motosiklet yolculuğumdan ve bu tutkumdan
bahsedecek olsam da aslında hikaye şöyle
başlıyor benim için
Bu benim hayatımda 9 yaşındayken
Antalya'da atletizmden kazandığım ilk
madalyam
bu yine Antalya'dayken juda yaptığım
yıllardan kazandığım bir madalya
bu Siirt'te tekvando yaptığım dönemden
kalma bir madalya
bu yine Bilecik'te atletizme devam
ettiğim zamanlardan kalma bir madalya
Yani demem o ki Aslında ben asker çocuğu
olmam sebebiyle bütün çocukluk hayatımı
toplam 10 farklı şehirde geçirdim o
dönemde de en fazla 2 sene aynı okulda
okuyabildim ve nerede hangi okulda hangi
spor branşı varsa onunla bir şekilde
devam ettim ve müsabak ve lisanslı Bir
sporcu olarak çok küçük yaşta başladım
spor hayatına Akademik olarak da
başarılı bir çocuktum hem spor hayatım
Hem Okul hayatım Hem sürekli taşınma
maratonu bir şekilde devam ediyordu 14
yaşlarında Tabii Sizlerin de bildiği
gibi bir üniversite Hangi üniversiteye
gideceğim hangi Bölümü okuyacağım stresi
oluyor derslerimin nispeten iyi yani
gitmek istediğim her bölüme birazcık
dişimi sıkarsam gidebilirim Öyle olunca
aileden bir baskı var sülalede
üniversiteye gidecek İlk çocuk benim
bütün Gözlerimde
siyah olmak istediğime karar verdim
dedim ki ben şey olayım bunun için ne
yapayım İstanbul'a gideyim İngilizce
İşletme okuyayım iyi bir üniversite
kazanayım 4 sene boyunca kafamda sadece
bu var duvarlarımı grafitilerle böyle
boyamışım kitaplarım falan
hazırlanıyorum
İstanbul'a geldim üniversiteye başladım
Bu arada da
yöneticilerle tanışmak istiyorum ki bu
dünyanın iç yüzü nasıldı yani
o arada 6 ayımda kendime bir kartvizit
bastırmıştım Bu arada üzerinde de
evrenin en başarılı suya adaya geliyor
Yazıyor Özgüven patlaması yaşıyorum bunu
da tanıştım üst düzey yöneticilere
veriyorum yani diyorum ki bir gün bana
ihtiyacınız olacak Bunu saklayın Tabii
adam da bakıyor ya da işte hanımefendi
ben işte 18 yaşındayım ilk Senem diyorum
o da bana kartvizcisini veriyor zaten
beklediğim hareket o kalp vizesi
alacağım ve dönüp hemen mail yazacağım
randevu alacağım ki hani daha uzun
sohbetler edebileceğim birçoğunun evine
Hani barbekü partilerine falan gitmiştim
zaten
istediğim o Samimiyeti kurabilmekti bunu
kurduktan 6 ay sonra ben siyah olmak
istemediğime de karar verdim kesinlikle
diyor olmayacaktım bu meslek bana göre
değildi ve 4 sene üniversiteyi kazanmak
için uğraştım 6 ayındayım
üniversiteyi okuyorum ve o meslekten de
vazgeçtim
Allah'tan Sürekli çalıştığım bir dönemdi
ve 19 yaşında kendi organizasyon
şirketimi kurdum konser organizasyonu
yapıyordum 20 yaşında ilk kafemi açtım
yine 19 yaşındaydım Okan Bayülgen'in ilk
katıldığımda engelli çocuklar için
yardım kampanyaları düzenliyordum böyle
böyle çok aktif bir hayatım var çok
farklı iş kollarında çalışıyordum
kafemi açtığım dönemde Alanya'ya gidip
geliyorum sürekli Aslında konsol
organizasyonu yapmak için gittiğim Bir
otelde bir yeri beğendim ve 3 aylık diye
Orayı açtım 3 sene işletmek zorunda
kaldım sürekli git gel yapıyorum ve
aşırı yoğunum Ama kafamda da Hala
aklımın bir köşesi yüreğimde yani Ben
hangisini yapmak istiyorum ben ne
yapacağım Ne yoğunlaşacağım bu
sorgulamalar hep devam ediyor Bir
arkadaşımız ziyarete gittim Bir
motosiklet gördüm
öylece duruyor aslında motosikletinde
bir suçu yok kenarda bekliyordu
ama benim o ana kadar hayatımda
motosiklette kullanan kimse yok yani
motosikletin konusunu açan kimse olmadı
hiçbir bilgim yok Sadece en sevdiğim
renk yeşil benim orada da yeşil bir
motosiklet duruyor
sahibi olan amcaya sordum tanımıyorum da
adamı öyle bir tür gezmek istedim merak
ettim yani çok güzel duruyordu nasıl bir
şey acaba diye başıma geleceklerden
haberim yok tabii o anda
amca da beni tanımıyor ama bindik bizim
Motosiklete gidiyoruz sadece korkarsan
sırtıma vur dedi Tamam dedim ama rüzgar
hissetmekle birlikte Hani korku ne
kelime Ben adama sürekli amca daha azdı
daha hızlı diyorum işte mutluluğumu
anlatmaya çalışıyorum ki birazcık daha
dolaştırsın beni diye yarım saatten daha
az bir süre sonra indim ben
motosikletten indim Ama o an yeni bir
karar aldım hayatımla ilgili kesinlikle
motosiklet almam gerekiyordu ve Hani o
motosikleti kullanan Ben Olmalıydım
bu aklıma girdikten sonra ve ben o
Rüzgarı hissettikten sonra sürekli
amcanın yanına gidiyorum işten çıkıyorum
amcanın yanına gidiyorum Motosiklete
bakıyorum birazcık daha gezeyim
motosikleti inceliyorum internetten
Videoları izliyorum motosiklet nasıl
kullanılır bunu öğrenmeye çalışıyorum
Tabi bu esnada önce Annem sonra babam
sonra ablam bir iyileşip birisi kansere
yakalandı ve yani aile Hayatımda çok
inişli çıkışta çalışmak zorundayım Zaten
çalışıyorum normal olarak dersler zaten
hepiniz biliyorsunuz Bir de final proje
onlar devam ediyor ama benim Aklımın
böyle yüzde seksenim motosiklette kaldı
yani kesin motosiklet almam lazım
o ara benim kafa hayatım çok
yoğunlaşmaya başladı
kafede Alanya'da Ben İstanbul'dayım
Sürekli gidiyorum geliyorum işlerim
büyümeye başladı işte masa sevdim artık
çalışanlar arttı Hatta öyle bir noktaya
geldik ki Ben okulu uzatmak zorunda
kaldım ve 4 sene okuduğum okulun kep
atma törenine gidemedim kafedeki
ogedizasyona denk geliyordu mezuniyet
törenime katılmadım
ama güzel kısmı şu oldu Motosiklete
alabildim yaklaşık bir sene sonra
motosikleti aldım ama işlerin
yoğunlaşması ile birlikte okuldan da
mezun oldum ama benim artık Hani gece
alarm kurupta uykudan sürmek için
uyandığım motosikletimi ayıracak vaktim
kalmadı işlerim çok iyi gidiyor Evet çok
emek verdiğim 3 sene boyunca Emek
verdiğim Kahve çok güzel bir noktada
şubeleşme teklifleri alıyorum ama benim
yine aklıma köşesi sadece motorda Yani
daha fazla sürmem lazım kamp yapmak
istiyorum mesela sürüp sabah sürerek
başlamak uyandığım şey uyuduğumda Hani
çadırımı atayım motorum yanımda olsun
böyle Hayaller kafamda dönüp durmaya
başladı
bir gün sabaha doğru 5 gibi Eee dedim ki
ben bu kafeye bırakmam lazım biliyorum
herkes bana saldıracak yani Yakın
çevremden yedirgi giyecekler ama o ana
kadar gelen İlayda da zaten hep oydu O
anneyi yapmak istiyorsan ben onu
yapıyordum Yani aslında yüreğimin sesini
dinliyordum dedim ki ben burada kalırsam
bu kafe büyüyecek şu veleşecek benim
sorumluluklarım artacak ben bu
Motosiklete binemeyeceğim ama benim iç
sesim onunla ilgili bir şeyler yapmam
gerektiğini ve orada benim hani içimdeki
bir boşluğun onunla dolacağını bana
söylüyordu tamamen his ama
Sabaha kadar uyumadım Otel sahibi geldi
Bütün anahtarları kafedeki her şeyiyle
birlikte ve bütün kazancımla birlikte
bıraktım Çünkü bir gün iki gün daha
kalsaydım Belki kalabilirdim orada devam
edebilirdim daha fazla üzerine düşünmek
istemediğimi ve sadece hayallerimi
satmak istemediğimi ve bugün burada bunu
bırakmak istediğimi söyleyip sırt
Çantamı aldım Motosiklete bindim yola
çıktım işsizim artık
ama sürüyorum Motosikletim yanımda ve
çok mutluyum Ondan sonra bir süreçte
Gerçekten mutlu oldum hissettiğim
anlarda benim bu motosikletle alakalı
bir şeyler yapmam gerektiği bunu nasıl
yapabileceğim hayatıma nasıl daha fazla
dahil edebileceğim sorusunu soruyordum
sürekli kendime bir yandan tabii yine
işte 3-5 ay sonra başka bir işe girdim
çalışmaya başladım ama Motosiklete daha
fazla vakit ayırabileceğim bir iş bu
arada sportif tarafı yok yani Hayatımda
sonra bir gün bunun yarışları olduğunu
öğrendim kendi kendime Şile virajlarında
Viraj yaparken bir abi geldi Çok güzel
Viraj yapıyorsun Niye yarışmıyorsun dedi
o şekilde yarışları öğrendim yarışmaya
Karar verdim çünkü benim gibi bir çocuk
için hani 9 yaşından beri müsabak
sporcuyum en çok sevdiğim şey motosiklet
ve bunun ve spor branşı olduğunu
öğrenince çok heyecanlandım yarışmaya
karar verdim hazırlıklarımı yaptım
yarışa gittim
Ama şu gördüğünüz tulum ekipmanın olması
gerekiyormuş ve Türkiye'de bu satılmıyor
Yani benim bedenim için satılmıyor Ben
motosikleti aldım piste gittim ama beni
piste sokmuyorlar Çünkü ekipmanım yok
Ondan sonra 2 sene sürdü benim bu
Ekipmanları toplayabilmem Çünkü yurt
dışında satılıyor burada yok Ee hepsini
toplasan bir motor parası zaten yapıyor
2 sene gittim geldim sadece yarışları
izledim Ondan sonra ekipmanlarımı
tamamladım ilk yarışıma girdim o dönem
ablam kanser hastası ve hastanede
kemoterapi alıyor Benim de tek istediğim
yarışa gidip kürsüde bitirip O bayağı
ablama götürmek
piste hiç giremedim ama bir özel bir
motosiklet markasının davetiyle
İspanya'ya bir lansmana gittim o
lansmanı Aslında benim için dönüm
noktası oldu oradaki sürüş performansım
ve motosikleti olan tutkum yurt
dışındaki firmalar tarafından çok dikkat
çekti Ben sonra Global bir lastik
firmasından iş teklifi aldım orada Hem
test pilotu olacaktım hem tanıtım
videolarını çekecektim hem de onlar için
organizasyonlar yapacaktım yaklaşık
2-2,5 senelik bir İspanya serüveni
başladı Benim için
Avrupa'nın çeşitli şehirlerin ülkelerine
gidiyorum sürekli motosiklet sürüyorum
lastik test ediyorum ama sokakta
sürüyorum yani Motosiklete
böyle bir etkinlik için Ha bu arada da
ablam kanser olduğunda ona bir söz
vermiştim Ben diğerleri Bayağı kötü
gidiyordu yani zor atlattık sürece o
dönemde çocukluk hayali Venedik de
ablamın Venedik'e gidip gondolabına
binmek
Motosiklete binmeyi de çok seviyor
kucağıma alıp bindiriyorum böyle arka
koltuktan sonra ben biniyorum
bana demişti ki eğer bu hastalığı da
atlatırsam benim motosikletle ve ne diye
götürür müsün söz verdim ben de ona
götürürüm dedim 3 senenin sonunda Biz
ablamın temizi raporunu aldık bu
İspanya'da olduğum süreçte de bunu
projelendirerek şöyle bir şey yapmıştık
hastalık raporunu öğrendiğim saatten
temiz raporunu aldığımız saate kadar
geçen her saatte 1 kilometre yazdık ve
onun hastalıkla geçirdiği bütün 3
senenin Zaferini kutlamak adına
İstanbul'dan Venedik'e kadar İtalya'ya
komple dolaşarak motosikletle bir Rota
yaptık ve Belçika bir firma tarafından
bu belgesele çekildi
benim motosiklet Yani ben sabahtan
akşama kadar motosikletlerim ve gayet
mutluyum Ama kafamda hala piste bu işin
sportif tarafı var Bu arada Türkiye'de
artık pisti olmuyor çünkü pistimiz yok
tadilatı alındı Biz İspanya heves
pistine girdik iş için ama o bir yarış
haftalarına denk geldi Dolayısıyla ben
bir sürü yarış takımının içine düştüm
işte yarıştırılır yarışçılar
otomatik olarak direkt ağlamaya başladım
yalnız Neden ben onların içinde değilim
Neden buradayım Şimdi oraya dahil olmam
lazım İşte aradığım Fırsat bu diye
Gittim takımlarla konuşmaya başladım
İşte ben de burada yarışmak istiyorum Ne
yapmam gerekiyor tabi karşılaştığım
manzara şu an nerede yaşıyorsun yaşın
kaç bu pisti kaç döndün o pisti ben
gelip dönemem çünkü yani ofiste dönmek
için bir zaman atmak için burada bir 10
gün vakit geçirmem lazım Böyle bir
imkanım yok Türkiye'de yarış
düzenlenmiyor Ben şu anda aktif olarak
yarışmıyorum ve Evet o zaman ben 27
yaşındayım
yaşımın Çok geç oldu aktif olarak
yarışmadığım sürece orada
yarışamayacağım ve o pislerdeki
zamanlarımı bilmeden beni bir takıma ve
şampiyona yerleştiremeyeceklerini
söylediler
Ama bu benim suçum değil dedim Sonuçta
ben 21 yaşında tanıştım motosikletle ve
Hani ailem Ben 2-3 yaşındayken benim
Motosiklete başlatmamış zaten hani öyle
bir şeyden haberleri de yok En azından
bir şansı hak etmiyor muyum diye sordum
yapabileceğimiz bir şey yok dediler ve
ben oradan devam ettim tekrar Belçika'ya
gittim
yaklaşık bir ay sonra içlerinden Birisi
eski motospu şampiyonu Luiz olsa o
konuşmamdan etkilenmiş numaramı buldu ve
beni aradı dedi ki işin çok zor Yaşın
çok geç Ee buradakiler Çünkü maksimum 5
yaşında başlıyor motosikletle yarışmaya
başlıyor yurt dışında Yani ben şu an 32
yaşındayım ve baktığınız zaman
motospuyla insanlar 32 yaşında bu işten
emekli oluyorlar
Dolayısıyla Çünkü bu ciddi kondisyon da
gerektiren bir insanı yoran bir spor
sürekli sağını solunuz bir tarafınız
kırılıyor
ama dedi bir şansı hak ediyorsun dedi
Biz sana bir gün pisti ayarlayacağız gel
dedi Çık zamanını at Eğer yarışmak
istediğin şampiyonadaki
yarışçıların zaman barajının içinde
kalabilirsen o gün dedi Biz sana bir
şans vereceğiz dedi Zaten aradığım
fırsat buydu benim hemen dedim ben
İstanbul'a dönerim Türkiye'ye giderim
işte bana İşte herkes yardımcı olur
çünkü Türkiye'de ilk defa bir kadın
böyle bir seçmeye gidecek beni
çalıştırırlar motor Beyler o arada
motorum yok çünkü motor verirler Ben
antrenman yaparım ve bir buçuk ay sonra
bomba gibi giderim oraya dedim Böyle
olmadı
Türkiye'ye döndüm
anlattığım herkes Saçmalama dedi 1 yaşım
çok geçti onlar için iki oradakiler çok
hızlıydı Çünkü motosikletin üzerine
doğmuşlardı üç Ben üç senedir piste hiç
girmemiştim onlar çok antrenmanlıydı
sadece ve sadece bana neden olmayacağını
söylediler Ama nasıl yapabileceğimi
kimse söylemedi
Ama tabii ki benim yüreğim Bu arada
yanıyor yani orada olmak ve orada
yarışabilmek aşkıyla O zamanki
antrenörüm Tolga Prag ve Ekin ikisi bana
inandı dedi ki En azından bir deneyelim
Ne kaybederiz Tamam dedim pistlerden
izin almaya başladı En azından go kart
hislerinden yani büyük pistlerde değil
de izin vermediler çünkü boş bir hayalin
peşinde koştuğumu düşündüğünde hepsi
Biz de İzmir'de Bir tır parkı bulduk boş
bir tır parkı plastik kukalardan
yarışacağım Pistin küçük halini simüle
ettik bir markadan bir test pilotu aldık
Onu yarış modifikasyonları yapmamıza
izin vermediler Cadde haliyle yarış
antrenmanı yapmam gerekiyordu ama olsun
motosiklet vardı onu aldık ve o tır
parkında çalıştık yaklaşık 7-8 gün ben o
parkta çalıştım ama asıl Pistin
haritasını çıkarttım Google'dan
YouTube'daki videolardan böyle ön
kameralardan yarışçılar o pistte nerede
fren atıyor hangi virajda gidiyorlar
Öyle Pistin ideal çizgisini çizdim ve
sürekli Rüyamda yarışıyordum ofiste
sonra bir PlayStation aldım ama daha
önce PlayStation oynamadığım için o
kumandayı kontrol edemedim oyunu alıp
piste ezberlemek istiyordum
kullanamayınca mahalledeki küçük
çocukları topladım onları oynattım ben
izledim Böylelikle ezberledim
ve seçmeye gittim seçmeye gittim piste
ilk çıktığımda Luis cardosa ve Ekibi
bana Sen daha önce bu pisti dönmüşsün
dedi gelmez bu zaman dedi Hayır dönmedim
dedim dönmüşsün ama dedim dönmedim dedim
ve o kağıdı aldım getirdim ama bir aydır
Rüyamda dönüyorum dedim Real olarak ilk
defa Şu an burada döndüm orada O zamanı
attım attıktan sonra beni 2 haftalık bir
Katar kampını aldılar eğitim aldılar
takım görüşmelerim başladı Benim için
her şey inanılmaz mükemmel gidiyordu
tabi oradaki seçmeden sonra ve ben o
zaman atınca Türkiye'de de birçok kişi
bana yapamazsın diyenler de beni aramaya
başladılar Biz ne yapabiliriz şimdi diye
Ama artık Hani Katar ve İspanya Bana
sahip çıkmıştı o noktada derken pandemi
çıktı
ve benim için
şampiyona kapandı
2019-2020 Sadece Avrupa vatandaşları
katılabildi yarışlara
2021'de yarışlara bir buçuk ay kadar bir
zaman var Bana yarışabileceğimi
söylediler Ama sponsor yok yani ben
hazırlık yok zaten Türkiye'de pisti
yoktu antrenman yok
son güne kadar bekledim belki dedim bir
yerden bir şey çıkar çıkmayınca bankaya
gittim kredi çektim Dedim ki Kervan
yolda düzelir ileride Sen bir başla bu
sezona devamlı Nasılsa gelir
Öylelikle gittim sonra tabii ki birçok
firma sesimi duydu oradaki başarılarımda
da bana Start Alman yeterli demişlerdi
aslında Çünkü 24 kişi Start alıyoruz Ve
ben pisti hiç bilmiyorum Sadece yarışta
Girit çizgisini diziliyoruz
orada da sıralama yarışlarında mesela
Start alırken en hızlı pilottan %5 yavaş
olma şansınız var yarışabilmek için ve
en hızlıları en hızlı 6 kişi dünya
şampiyonasından geliyorlar
ilk girişimde 8 kişiyi geçtim daha önce
ofislerde tecrübesi olan 16 bitirmiştim
çok motivasyonum arttı devam edeceğime
kesin kararlıydım 2021 güzel bir sezon
olarak bitti Bu arada 2021'de ben
Avrupa'da yarışacağım zaman
Türkiye'deki sporcuları ve bitmişti
tadilatı Türkiye'de bu sporu yapmak
isteyen diğer kadınları düşündüm bana da
çok fazla mesaj geliyordu sosyal
medyadan Onlar da benim yerimde olmak
istiyordu ama hani bunun ne kadar zor
olduğunu ya da ofiste girmek için ne
yapmış olduğum Vermiş olduğum mücadeleyi
2 satır mesajda anlatamazdım ve
şevklerini de kırmak istemediğim için o
talebi görünce önce Federasyon ve birçok
markayla
bir görüşme yaptım dedim ki bakın
Türkiye'de çok fazla kadın sporcu kadın
sporcu yetiştirebiliriz kadın sürücü var
piste girmek isteyen bu insanları Ben
eğitim verebilirim gönüllü olarak
arkadaşlarımdan sağdan soldan tulumlar
topladım Çünkü biliyordum ki pistte
alabileceğimiz zaman onlara verecek bir
tulum yoktu Türkiye'de bütün bu
altyapıyı yaptıktan sonra
yaklaşık 25-26 tane kadın sporcuyu kadın
sürücü seçmeye aldık ve onları pistlerle
tanıştırdık Onları eğitimler verdik bu
sene yine aynı şampiyona aynı
organizasyon devam etti
2021 ve 2022 senesinde Toplam 30 35 tane
kadın sürücü pistlerle tanıştırdık
yaşları 14 ile 30 yaş arasında değişiyor
şu anda bu spor Bence en azından 5-6
tane daha kadın sporcu kazandı
Türkiye'de
onlarla beraber sürmek onların
gelişimini görmek yarın bir gün
Avrupa'da milli takımda belki bana ve bu
oluşturduğum projeden bana ve takım
arkadaşı çıkacak olması çok heyecan
verici süreçler
2023 için
yine Türkiye'de yapmam gereken ve
başlattığım bu organizasyonla ilgili
daha da büyüterek daha fazla kitleleri
ulaşarak daha Küçük yaşlarda ki kız
çocuklarına ulaşarak
projelerimi büyütmek istiyorum Onun
dışında benim için Avrupa Şampiyonası
Avrupa şampiyonluğunu alana kadar devam
edecek oradaki o kupayı istiyorum
sizlere de söylemek istediğim bana ilk
pentaton'a girdiğimden beri etrafındaki
herkes yapmak istediğim şeyle ilgili
birçok kişi diyeyim daha doğrusu
herkesle miyim birçok kişi yapamazsın
dedi ama yapamazsın benim için Aslında
yapabileceğimin en büyük kanıtı Çünkü
Kim bana yapamazsın dediyse ben onu
yaptım sadece benim yürekten bunu
yapabileceğime inanmam yeterli oldu
benim için
hayallerinizin peşinden gidin belki Çok
klişe bir söz ama gerçekten mutlaka
gidin Eğer bir şekilde yüreğinize
düştüyse bir tutku Ben bugüne kadar
tutkum olmayan hiçbir şeyin peşimde
koşmadım ama hiçbir tutkumu da
bırakmadım O yüzden sizlere
söyleyebileceğim ruhunuzun Gözü hiç
kesilmesin
hayallerinizin peşinden Tam Gaz sürmeye
devam edin
[Alkış]